[Music]
you're using power tools now in a very
suggestive way on stage i think we have
a still here of you what are you doing
there it looks like sparks are flying
off your crotchal zone yes
yeah so i so i made this like chastity
belt looking thing and that's during a
song i wrote called gold trans am so i
have one car and it's a gold trans am
and i wrote a song about it kind of
comparing it playfully to my vaginal
region
and so because they're both magical
you know
yes
so then they come with a warranty
[Laughter]
just throwing stuff around i'm having
fun
i'll be good
so anyways no i just wanted to like take
power tools and show like
sparks and
magic right so you're grinding it there
and it's is that dangerous at all super
dangerous yeah yes i think yeah you
don't want to be doing that it probably
says on the box don't do that yeah
don't put this up
against
your sexual organs and make sparks fly
out
not for genital use yeah
but it looks so cool and like my fans
are way into it so i'm like woo but then
at this one show when i was in like
wercter i was doing that and all of a
sudden i started getting electrocuted
while i was grinding on my vagina
and it was super scary and intense and i
was like and i think everyone thought i
was like i just thought you were part of
the act yeah i didn't
so so yeah but you're okay now yeah
we're good okay
uh kesha my crazy beautiful life it's
the second season of the show yeah you
got your family in this show
i do you me like the first season i feel
like you really got to know me and now
this season you get to know my crazy
family they're all bad
just like me
and you get to know
me
a little better in the days like i think
i brought a clip for you okay and this
clip i believe you're is this you
camping yeah i love you well one thing
you get to know about me in this season
is my love of the outdoors okay so this
really just
is an example of how much i just i'm
really dedicated to being outside and
outdoors let's take a look at this clip
from kesha my crazy beautiful life
i love camping
you can only see the milky way when
you're camping
sorry about being
i hope it bites your vagina
it's not very roomy i don't want to camp
i do
come on stop smooshing me again
oh pushing me against the other no
you're smushing me into the wool stop
saying stop smushing me to me
i really [ __ ] hate camping right now
[Applause]
the key is that there's drinking
involved is that the idea well the part
of that you didn't see is when we were
chugging like two bottles of tequila
right
and twerking on each other
right it's all in the cub scout manual